plus d'un millier de visiteurs
aujourd'hui au château d'azay-le-rideau
cette fois plus que dimanche dernier
alors bien sûr l'effet gratuité est
indéniable c'est l'occasion on a vu
aussi à cet événement noël au château je
voulais aussi voir la décoration et puis
j'en profite aussi pour faire une petite
sortie avec les enfants mais c'est
également le moyen de conjuguer la
féerie des châteaux avec l'esprit festif
des célébrations de fin d'année une
démarche conjointe entreprises par les
plus prestigieuses demeures du val de
loire les chatons en touraine mettre en
place maintenant en hiver une décoration
de noël qui fait que ça renouvelle
l'attrait pour les visiteurs chaque
édifice s'empare d'un thème festif les
lumières allonger les rêves gourmand
azay-le-rideau ici une artiste
plasticienne à concocter des mets de
noël pour le plaisir des yeux et des
visiteurs ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas visité le château il y en a
profité du fait qu'il soit décorée pour
noël avec les enfants pour leur
présenter un peu le château aussi ça
nous permet aussi de découvrir une
nouvelle ambiance parce que en été c'est
pas la même chose quand l'hiver là avec
toutes les décorations c'est vraiment
superbe donc on en profite ça nous
permet au cidre de reparler de tout
l'historique on habite azay-le-rideau
donc c'est important aussi pour les
enfants et cela fonctionne aussi bien
pour les châteaux renaissance que
moyen-âge et celui de l'ange et voit sa
fréquentation doubler en décembre avant
moi décembre c'était très très calme un
petit peu mieux pendant les vacances
mais c'était pas exceptionnel là on a
une fréquentation équivalente à des
vacances de pâques donc un début de
saison pour nous qui démarre en général
très fort chaque année s'approprier les
fêtes le moyen de relancer
ponctuellement la saison touristique
avec une clientèle familiale
essentiellement locale ou parisienne